Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and in this video it's just going to be very
quickly on just some questions and some answers that we frequently get when people ask
us about what is the right for sheet, what does it do.
You can find a whole bunch of information in my book Stop Fighting Cancer and that's available
as a free download on our website, cuttersclinic.com, as well as you can purchase the book on Amazon.
And I encourage you to do that, there's a bunch of detailed information on the rife that
may be helpful if you're a skeptic, you're just trying to figure this out whether this is
going to work for you or not.
The picture here is the type of rife we use, it is the true rife F117, this picture is
of a little older model but they don't look a whole lot different.
And it is a light frequency generator, that's what a rife machine does and it works at a
quantum physics level.
To help, helps kill bacteria in your body, viruses in your body, cancer cells in your body.
So it works really well for cancer and it works well for Lyme disease and other bacteria
infections, chronic infections, pathogens, viruses, fungus, mold, anything livid is a good
tool.
And that's another question that I often get is, okay, let's say if my sole problem is
because of a mercury toxicity, well, rife really is the proper tool to be used for that.
And that's important to know that it is a tool, another question I get, is it a miracle cure?
It's not a miracle cure, I tell people that over and over, I wish I had a magic wand,
I could just wave over patients and they're going to be better.
And I don't think that that's what the rife is going to do.
Now, I'll be honest, we've seen literal miracles happen with the rife.
I've seen miracles in my own body with the rife, it healed my toward rotator cuff.
I still have no physiological understated on how it did that with me.
I was in a sling for three weeks, finally called the orthopedic surgeon to have surgery, did
the rife at one time, took my pain away, did it two other times, it's all I've done that was
five years ago, completely healed my shoulder.
I have no stick idea how that happened, to be honest with you, I can't figure it out.
We've seen cancer patients that were at the brink of death, come on of that.
Was it the rife?
Was it the nutrition?
Was it, I have no idea what it was, but we've seen miracles.
But it doesn't mean that it's going to be a miracle cure for everybody.
We've had cancer patients that we started with the rife and they still passed away.
So there's no guarantees, it's not a stake oil treatment for anything, it is a tool.
It's a tool just like the hammer is a tool, if you use it properly, it can be beneficial.
If you try to use it in the wrong way, it's not going to work very well.
And that's the problem really with the practice of all medicine.
I mean, medicine with cancer patients really has three tools in their tool bank.
They're going to do surgery, they're going to do chemotherapy.
They're going to do radiation.
Well, they don't have any other tools, but in fact, they deny the use of any other tools.
Nutrition doesn't work, diet doesn't make any difference to cancer.
You know, they'll claim all of these things that the only way to treat cancer is
chemo radiation and surgery.
What's about your nonsense?
So the more tools you could have of the tool bank, the better.
The rife is just another tool.
It's not a substitute, it's not something to use alone.
It's something you want to add to your tool bank to use for your treatment.
Really important there.
Can you see miracles with the rife?
Obviously, well, how the rife works is based upon frequencies.
It's usually light frequency.
And frequencies is really the makeup of everything.
Quite the physics tells us that everything, done in the smallest particle,
is energy vibrating in a specific frequency.
And if you could affect the frequency of that tissue, you could, it'd affect that tissue.
So I don't want to mislead you that it's a miracle care, but I don't want to mislead you
that I haven't seen miracles with it.
So I just know that God could use a lot of different things, even chemo radiation, and
surgery.
So it's just another tool in the tool bank.
Another question we get is can it hurt someone?
And I tell a lot of patients that the only way you're going to get hurt with the rife is
if you trip over it.
That's not altogether true.
I mean, that is true for a cancer patient and somebody who's just trying to use the rife
for colds or infections or flus or keep their family safe, you're sleeping with the bulb.
The only way that you can hurt yourself with the rife is if you have Lyme disease.
So Lyme disease and gram negative bacteria have it, it's cell membrane, what are called
lipopolysaccharides.
And I write a lot about this and have videos about this.
So I'm not going to get too deep into this.
But when you kill Lyme disease too quickly, you liberate a lot of Lyme polysaccharides and
there are big enough particles that they'll stimulate an immune response in itself.
So that your immune system will turn on to kill those lipopolysaccharides and most people
that are that I see have have stage three phase three live, which is means they're in an
autoimmune phase.
And when you stimulate an immune response quite sharply and you already have antibodies
to self tissue, you'll kill that which you have antibodies to first and you will in
a head make yourself sick.
That's what's called typically a herx reaction.
So we have to be careful not to hurt someone.
So yeah, you can't if you kill too quickly with the rife and you have Lyme disease, you
can make yourself sick.
You're not going to hurt yourself permanently, but you can make yourself miserable.
That's why we never want our Lyme patients to herx and it's very, very, very important how
you write those programs and how fast you use kill programs with a patient with Lyme disease.
So do be careful with that because in a sense, you can't hurt somebody that way.
My question for everybody, when they are asking about a rife machine and stuff is like, why
would you try?
It's another tool in the tool bank.
Why would you try to use this?
The struggle that we get in our practice quite honestly is we have cancer patients, 85% of
the cancer patients that walk in our door are stage four and I wish they would come in
earlier.
I understand a lot of people find out they have cancer and they're already in stage four.
But it hurts me when I have a patient who will take them because we believe God is sending
them our way.
But we have a patient that comes out of our office found out they had cancer four years
ago.
I've done chemo, radiation and surgery and now we're giving a few weeks to live and nothing
is going to help and they walk in our door and they get mad because they don't get cured.
It's like, whose fault is this?
Why didn't you come in earlier?
The rife is not a magic wand.
It's not a magic wand.
You can't just start using the rife and it's going to cure you.
You have to have your body has the healing recuperative powers enough to be able to heal.
So starting off with a rife when you find out you have cancer is the smartest thing to
do.
It will help the chemo work better.
It will help the surgery heal faster and it'll help your liver detox from the radiation
much better if you're using alternative therapies along with standard ecological therapies.
If you're going that route, so it just doesn't make any sense that you're separating the
two and I just wish people would wait to investigate this stuff until they're on their deathbed.
It's just smart to get started as soon as possible and I understand too we've had people
that literally were given two weeks to live by Mayo and live for another four years.
So we've seen it both ways but it hurts my heart when I have people come in and they're
on their last leg.
So how we use the rife is we have, we program it so people sleep with it because I don't
want to interrupt interrupting their day and want them to live through the day.
It's easy to use, it's easy to program as far as the patient's use of it and it works
fantastic.
We're living proof of it, my wife had kids there, I've had all sorts of things, we use a rife
at home, my grown kids with kids have rife at home.
It's a great tool but again it's a tool, it's a tool that you should have in your tool bag.
I hope this helps.